Sponges are strange creatures.
Aside from being some of the
oldest extant species on Earth,
these invertebrates have a have an odd way
of maintaining rigidity in their bodies--glass.
Sponges have hard structures within their bodies
called spicules, crystalline forms made from amorphous silica
that grow and branch to form wicked shapes.
Researchers looked into how the sponge
forms these highly symmetrical structures,
and how they become so complex.
Under the microscope,
spicules from three different kinds of sponges
all have the same crystalline hexagonal structure,
like a snowflake.
Even though this basic structure
is the same across species,
the spicules then take many different shapes,
such as pointy needles,
branched trees, or spiked spheres.
Looking inside using X-ray nano-tomography
gives us a clue into how spicules develop.
The internal scans show
that the proteins inside of spicules --
known as axial filaments --
predetermine the shape of the growing spicule.
While all modern ways for humans to make glass
involve large amounts of heat, it turns out
that sponges don’t need this.
Because the spicules
grow the crystalline branches
along a single filament whose structure
is determined by protein folding
whioh is a biological process based on how
amino acids in the protein chain
interact with each other.
The sponges don’t need high temperatures
to generate these fine structures.
This biological process is similar
to experimental technologies just making their way
into manufacturing for solar cells
and other electronics.
So with a little more research, these ancient sponges
could make very modern technologies
easier to produce.